The
shrine maiden of Kannagi, who pays her custody with a sword, has threatened this country.
[Music]
I think there's still more
[Applause]
[Music]
This spring, Kamakura's Origami Machine will train origami
masters.  Those who had all the matches held after the tournament
Pit
At that time, by using the power of the sword, you can exercise various abilities.It
transforms into the energy body of the body, which is the basic tactic of copy and time, and it causes a
slight pain and a mental flinch.
[Music]
Iki City As
a result of using divine milk, it is possible to make a family out of normal time.
Yusei Maegashira The ones who made it to
the finals of the imperial match were Minoseki Gakuin's Zodiac Kanami and Heijo Gakuin's Jujo Biyori
Exciting but I can't stop trembling.
An attempt to assassinate the head of the family, Origami Yukari, fails.
I
have a request for
Mr. Eto's permission to create a work.
I'm sorry for the red team, I'm sorry Komecha, I and Hiyori-chan still can't get caught Why
?
There was a moment when something bad happened,
and I thought it was a mistake, but after
all, Hare is
tied to the origami by Hiyori
.  3
Thank you for Kanami-chan
After that, the two of them leaned in under the sound of their collaborators. Rui
offers a new color and
introduces a mysterious person, Feynman, to the two of you.
This welcomes you.
Sayaka is attacking me Sayaka has the ability to sustainably use a god called good life-enhancing grass
Strong closing
[music]
I'll open it I don't
know if you're ready to cut this guy
[music]
After this  It wasn't like this before this case
Nothing is transmitted from the chain,
but the sage who doesn't have fun
Denial
[music]
No,
or you won't play with me
[music]
Me
Escaping Sayaka's sealer  The designated meeting point
is Irozaki I'm aiming for Irozaki
[Music]
Part 2 Ota Ninosuke Gakuen's Masuko Buy
5 Hard Barom Main Weapon Location
Douga Gray
Nationwide Chigaku Kaorun
[Music]
These people will always be on the day
Hey, isn't it necessary to drive the cows
? Me and Ellen throw in the equipment, but after purging the tangles, they succeed in escaping.
The
former Sagami Bay disaster The
worst big store in history that appeared in Enoshima was Origami Murasaki and the special task force by the presidents of Urita now
subjugated
And my mother was also in the special task force  It's
not recorded in the record.
The only person who had the power to
destroy him was my mother.  Congratulations on your
return
[Music]
You guys have passed,
you two have already passed the grass test.
It
's a nice name for an organization to regain its proper form with a sword, isn't it? Kizoko:
Does the name Feynman sound familiar to you?
The idea is that you guys put us in that tree or something
?
by
I made an original
picture so that it would
be
divided into pieces.  I'm not a person
Passing by at that time I
got into the temporary command post of the single body guard l
Start
I got an ampoule that was used to harass people, but it was discovered by reading and a battle
ensued.  As if the power of reading is strong and puts us in a predicament,
but 4 is unable to control his own power and quickly
becomes
incapacitated.
On the other hand, in the tuplet, Katsuyuki, who was the president of the tuplet, was about to inject an album into the album.
At
the
Mogusa base, Tangle is told
about the worst truth of the Sagami Bay ex-Sagami 20 years ago from Akane, Gori's younger sister, and Feynman, Ellen's grandfather Friedman.
It is said that a certain Arada faction was subjugated by a special task force consisting of Hori-gani Enri and the current president of
Gourita.  His mother was Minato Fujiwara,
but not only has the aura subjugation of 20 years ago not ended,
but Gori, the head of the origami family, has a new relationship
, and his power has become even stronger than at that time.  In order to
counterattack, Namachi will receive special training at the north base.It
is said that a festival will be held in Nakazato.Namihi
8There is something I would like you and your wife to see.
Akane and Friedman tell him about the meaning of enshrining Noro, and
Kanami and Hiyori hold up an origami edge to overthrow
them.
Origami edge cla that absorbs Tsubame of the Imperial Guard, usually 4 seats
The strongest
me
Dream barely shakes off the pursuit Kanami and others escape at the teacher's mansion, but
the seed suffers catastrophic damage.
In the midst of that, a mysterious
phenomenon occurs in those days. It was 20 years ago.
What is it
[music]
t
I
don't have a
moment to spare The house I saw from the inside is for old age [music] [music] can go through a great project after this Hi Kong Tennen Rishin style capture
er
go  Hey, Hiyori-chan, Papa, don't wait I
still don't want to settle things down with that girl Why is it okay?
There are lyrics
me
this time this was standing
[music]
or something like that
I'm going
to hit it today
Thank you
ah ah ah
[music]
kei
Thank you
Taah,
maybe this is the place I
'm back The
young fruit trio
[Music]
This is the 2.10 jabe related to origami I
didn't have time to decide on God's next
[Music]
Hmm yeah yeah yeah
dare
tan
ni
yeah yeah
Well, just now, he's hit it,
our olds
have been completely read, I can see it, ah,
everything is a bottle
From there, I'll choose the best way
to go.
I dared to
let go I'm saying aa
[music]
What are
you doing?
In
this state, the possibilities are too visible and I can't reduce the
edges.
No, no,
ana
me,
go to Poisoned Sword Style,
nani
[music]
5-door princess
,
yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah
fold  It's been a
long time since I met
Mina-ton It's
impossible Ah
dee It's
impossible
Mmm,
this is one of my chains.It's a
way of looking at
it.I'm not going to send it when it's handed over.
[Music]It's
not directly connected
.
Moe shine pours down on the soul
It was like a shooting star
4 months after the subjugation related to origami
Incidents due to enclaves and aratama were occurring frequently
A new battle begins for Kanami and others
Close
[music]